it's a good thinking about doing videos
about movies when big movies aren't
theaters we get big trailers so the
trailers are Catching Fire which is the
new Hunger Games movie just came out and
if you haven't seen the Hunger Games you
don't want me to ruin it for you stick
around so I can ruin it for you in 3 2 1
so at the end of the Hunger Games
Katniss and Peeta both won The Hunger
Games together in an act of defiance
against the Empire and now emperor
gestahl from Final Fantasy 6 is really
pissed off so now he's wondering what to
do with these kids just wants to save
her skin I'll kill him that's easy but
Philip Seymour Hoffman is like if you
just kill her you're gonna murder her
that'll do no good to really destroy her
you have to destroy her reputation and
make her what she hates most namely us
Candice Everdeen is a symbol you don't
have to destroy her just her image
show them that she is one of us now
let them rally behind I'm taking a page
out of the book of Catwoman from Batman
Returns I like it and I really like this
that's proper escalation for this
situation these two kids just gave you
the finger now people are gonna have
hope what to do I don't know if this
emperor gets tall but it's stupid I
really kind of empathize with that guy
I'm like that's a [ __ ] situation I would
hate for that to happen with me that's
why we stick to being good guys my
favorite part of the trailer is that
part where that dudes getting his ass
kicked and Katniss intervenes guy pulls
his gun like it's gonna matter and she's
just like that dude kills her he martyrs
her and everyone rises up in rebellion
and he'll probably die because Emperor
Gaston will kill him plus she doesn't
have to put up with this [ __ ]
anymore it's really a win situation for
her he doesn't kill her well he doesn't
kill her I'm pretty sure she would
probably prefer him to actually kill her
what are the few times anyone's had a
gun to their face and they've been like
do it and I actually believe that they
want the person to kill them and end it
for what I know about Catching Fire this
is a small part of it it's like the
build up it doesn't even show The Hunger
Games scenario it gives you some insight
as to why they make the Hunger Games
scenario and Catching Fire The Hunger
Games scenario in Catching Fire
because Katniss has made the world a
place for all the other people who have
won the Hunger Games are now a threat
because they're like hey we can do more
than just win a game we can take down a
stupid piece of [ __ ] Empire because of
her they all pose a threat because of
her they all think they're invincible oh
yeah so they gotta go this movie looks
to step it up in a few places that
second chapter in the trilogy is usually
my favorite part usually because action
has been taken in the first one now
people have to deal with action in the
second one it's usually way more
intriguing there are a lot more gray
areas in that movie or book or game or
whatever Catching Fire seems to play on
that I'm looking forward to catching
fire are so Catching Fire have you seen
the trailer and are you looking forward
to this movie whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
may the odds be ever in your favor as I
give you a number three
you